hey everyone John Roker here really
excited for this interview today the
gentlemen I'm gonna interview here
you've seen him in shows like Empire he
was tried in Inhumans True Blood Castle
two Broke Girls House among others and
hey he was Ryu in street fighter
assassin's fist and in street fighter
resurrection he's arguably the star of
the first trailer for Quentin
Tarantino's Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood as he convinced Lee brought
Bruce Lee back to life for those of us
who are massive fans of Bruce Lee it was
incredible he's a martial artist none of
his own he just finished kicking my butt
out in the alley and I'm very glad to
welcome from the Midwest visiting LA now
the great Mike Mo how are you Mike Thank
You Jenna preciate him doing great yeah
how was how's your day been Gong's you
been going to other interviews as well
and doing all those kind of stuff like
what's your energy like like doing the
Hollywood thing I'm happy I just had a
bowl of pho something full and full of
energy for this film I'm super excited
to be here I've seen a bunch of your
interviews and colliders at the top of
my Twitter feed oh right on yeah and
what's the shirt you're wearing right
give us some shout out there it's an
honor just to be aged it is so represent
yeah respect Wendy always wants me to
become Asian but I can't do it let's
move on to question four I want to find
this out because like watching the
trailer and this is a
our friend Patrick reached out to me and
he was like he was he really such a star
for your like yeah Bruce Lee was
fantastic growing up for me those was a
certain age he was such an idol and then
to see someone bring him back to life
the way you have what was that process
like and I went and saw some of your old
interviews from 2004 tour videos from
2014-2015 you had already mastered the
voice and the move so it was almost like
you were prepping for this gak your
whole life how did this come about for
you starting from when I was a kid and
you know the first kung fu movie that
got me like cooked before I even started
martial arts was rumble in the Bronx
jacket and that was kind of like my
introduction then I was like my dad and
I would watch out the movies and then I
saw Enter the Dragon and that was like
it busted the work that the door wide
open and it was like the wormhole to not
only Bruce Lee but just martial arts
right house like I need to learn I need
to learn I need to learn so when I was
12 it took me about two years to
convince my parents you know they were a
little I was smaller than drunk and you
know fragile I'm sure they didn't want
me to like hurt myself or anything so
eventually I got my parents to sign me
up at the at the Taekwondo school next
to the grocery store that we go to and
from then on it was just that's been a
huge part of my life well and then just
just mimicking bruised and knowing Bruce
and learning about his philosophy and
just his way of life it really has been
kind of like a combination this role of
a lifetime of martial arts and then as I
journeyed to become an actor and so yeah
it's I'm still kind of pinching myself
that I get to play not only my idol but
you know in a movie directed by one of
the all-time great yeah actors well
let's let's go to there what was it like
being on set working with Quentin
Tarantino and bringing Bruce Lee back to
life because of course he's a massive
fan of 70s movies influenced by those
kinds of movies throughout his all his
films what was it like for you to work
with him and take this character on for
him he's he's a massive Bruce Lee fan
and he knows so much about every single
movie ever made it's unbelievable
actually I remember the first time I met
him when I auditioned for him we just
talked Bruce for like 20 30 minutes yeah
and then I did my thing and you know
he's so energetic I
I've never met somebody with such a
passion and when you meet somebody
that's so passionate about something you
can't help but be passionate about it so
you know from the moment I met him like
of course I was getting ready I prepped
for the audition but after I met him and
just felt how important this was to him
and how important Bruce was to him
personally into this film I put it in
overdrive man I told him like I said
leaving the room because I didn't know
if I would get the role if there would
be more steps I said mr. Tarantino I
promise if you pick me people are gonna
think Bruce Lee came back to life to be
in your film Wow and I think he kind of
chuckled that me looked at me because
he's tall right out of me like probably
he's thinking sure whatever kid you know
long process yeah I finally land the
role and his sets I I have I think I'm
still coming off the high of just being
on such a amazing set with you know all
stars just like yeah we're talking about
football earlier yeah yeah yeah you know
imagine being a Viking fan all your life
never making it to to the Super Bowl win
you know right but now I'm like on the
Patriots right and now you getting to
the Patriots Super Bowl time yeah Brad
Pitt's you know yeah
quarterback throwing me the ball and
yeah Tarantino's Belichick so yeah I I
that was awesome did you train like we
saw that fight with Brad Pitt is great
in the trailer did you work with repet
did you do the suck or was there another
student coordinator on said was helping
you with the martial art choreography so
a team so Zoey Bell who's working great
epic she's amazing she was the stunt
coordinator and then a guy Rob Alonso
who's kind of like I call him the Swiss
Army knife of martial arts he knows
everything he's a big Bruce fan as well
he's writing some Jeet Kune Do so
together they helped me prep and of
course like I've done martial arts in
the past I had my own school and I'm a
fifth degree in Taekwondo right but it's
different and I knew that going in like
Taekwondo and jeet kune do-- they're not
the same and i didn't pretend to think
they were the same so I you know I
worked my ass off to to make sure that
the martial arts was authentically Bruce
as much as I could have it yeah and big
props to Brad because he was there hour
after hour in between shooting you know
right he's one of the stars of the film
and he's on his breaks no he's not
relaxing
he's coming to the stunt riding to work
with you guys yeah yes so no it's it's
all us and of course we had great a
great team and great doubles helping us
come up with the fights and all that
stuff but yeah Quentin was very adamant
about having the action be done by us
right and the authenticity of it all did
you have conversations with him as you
were doing this film as you were on set
with him about Bruce like did you like
oh I want to keep this I like to have
this or like this would work better I
think it's like any that nature to kind
of bring your own years long expertise
and love of Bruce Lee to this character
you know he didn't really give me a lot
of direction in terms of the Bruce and
and you know kudos to him because I
think he trusted me as he knew yeah he
could sense through me yeah how
important this is a moment for me
personally right and also professionally
and I'm sure if I did something wrong I
would have been the first thing told me
that our last stunt rehearsal he pulls
me aside this was like two days before
we shot hmm before I started filming he
goes come here yeah
pulls me aside you know he's like
there's a sequence that the way I want
to do it
mmm it's all up to you to get it right
and if you can't do it I can't shoot it
the way I want to shoot it well yes sir
I got it sir you know yeah he's like and
then he gives me like alright well I
wouldn't hire you if I didn't believe
you could do it that's why I said I'm
your man that sounds like Belichick to
me yeah so you know it's I've never been
under such pressure yeah but I've never
had so much like belief in myself
because of the hours and years and you
know yeah and you've been building to
this moment I mean looking at your
career all the stuff you've done you
know as we mentioned Inhumans Triton but
stuff before that you know the work on
Empire are these other TV shows and
stuff with that you do a street fight
like all of that was you kind of
figuring this out this business career
out absolutely now you're at this spot
so like you've done your bones you
weren't just handed this role so that
must have been nice to have a director
of that caliber and that quality give
you
confidence in that moment because like
in my personal opinion as I'm looking at
you here and I'm talking to the fans
I think we're catching you just before
you become a star like a real big star
and and you've been working towards it
and those of us who respect that kind of
process like have nothing but love for
that I appreciate those those words yeah
you know I think I give him tons of
props for trusting me because if I were
a big-name director I could see like
this guy hasn't done the big you know he
hasn't worked with right you know and I
love my time on all the stuff I've done
before and honestly I was still exactly
like you said I'm still finding my way
yeah just like the characters in this
movie you know cliff and Rick they're
looking to navigate in a world of
Hollywood that's challenging and Bruce
himself you know something that I you
know discovered during my study of Bruce
is he wasn't just this legendary figure
that everybody has these memes and gifts
he was a real guy that was struggling to
find his mark right in Hollywood like
look he took his bones as well and he
had things taken from him he had things
that you know racially he had to fight
uphill against so without his groundwork
on a lot of that stuff like I'm not here
yeah I think that's I think that's why
you got to give a little bit of love to
Rob Cohen's dragon film the Bruce Lee
story because they did such a great job
of exposing that absolutely you didn't
know the other side of it and you know
of what he had to go through the thing I
want to talk to you I don't we can't
talk about details of the film but when
you're fighting Sharon Tate in the film
how does that go about when you have a
fight scene with Sharon Tate in the film
so I don't have a so with with Brad no
with Margot Robbie when you guys are
going at it do you have no because we
can't talk about play do we see a lot of
Bruce in the film is there do you know
I'm saying there's a lot more where that
scene came from yeah say that all right
all right we'll leave it there in terms
of the film what what is it about Bruce
Lee that inspires you because it's so it
seems to like when I'm watching your
videos you do that glass quote a lot in
those videos and they're really it seems
to speak really powerfully to you what
is it about Bruce himself that speaks to
you I think what transcends
makes him transcend over just any actor
or any star persona or any martial
artist even is his philosophy if you go
back and read his philosophies on not
only martial arts but life in general
ago he was literally 50 years ahead of
his time what he's saying in terms of
martial arts you know he was the first
guy that said no I'm not just gonna
stick to this one thing because it's
tradition right I'm gonna take whatever
I can learn you know what does he say
you know keep what is useful discard
what is not right like that is you know
he went against the grain on that so he
that's why people consider him the
grandfather of MMA yeah and yeah I try
to follow that in my own you know I'm a
Taekwondo guy but I teach my students
what I think is gonna be useful right
he's entered the dragon your favorite
Bruce Lee film it is I'm still is its it
still is boss and Chinese connection is
still I mean there are moments in other
films that are like amazing but Enter
the Dragon that was the first one that I
saw that those was also like the first
r-rated film I saw amazing fight season
okay so a lot of interesting you know
I'm sure my parents will hear my parents
didn't really speak English that well
okay so you know I learned a lot of
things about life through media through
TV show writer Bruce Lee so you know I
kind of learned that it was possible to
be a cool masculine you know ultra
awesome asian dude writings to Bruce and
Jackie and guys like that right so I
think that's why I kind of was able to
latch on to martial arts so well because
number one I saw it yeah and number two
I just clicked with me so hopefully
we'll get another generation of young
kids all of all genders and affiliations
or whatever that see this movie yeah and
remember what it was like
back in the 60s and how it's all
changing we can all find our own you
know thing that makes us feel confident
well that brings our next question
because another iconic Asian character
the people floated your name for is
shang-chi even patton oswalt on twitter
and was a nerd god when he
giving you his blessing to go and play
this role and tagging marvel I think he
did on that tweet as well dude is there
are you in contention for this is there
an update can you say anything about
that I don't know if I'm in contention I
know that it's a little ways off I'm a
huge fan of obviously of the Marvel
films I would love to do it would be a
dream to enter DC or marvel anything
like that but yeah I would like to think
that I mean I'm starting to become one
of those short Lister's right in any
role like that so I need anytime you can
you know get a guy like Kevin Feige
who's doing just incredible things he's
paving the way for all these other
people to follow the blueprint you know
the guys at 8711 chance the hell skied a
[ __ ] like man there's this is this is a
great time to be not only an actor but
an action actor right as well well I
would float out there it seems to be a
great time to be an Asian actor now it
seems more that's starting to become
more of a thing people are focusing on
bringing the Asian community into the
superhero world into the franchise world
yeah I hear rumors about Submariner
possibly being someone as well that
could be someone do you do you feel that
do you sense that that there you're
getting into more doors now than you did
before not just because you know the age
because of your talent but also because
they want to start looking at more Asian
actors for roles absolutely then you
know like big props to John Chu and
crazy Richards like that just showed you
know what what we patient Americans
believed already like of course there's
so many of us and we we want to see
ourselves and we want to be represented
in a way that all kids can feel like
they have an opportunity to do what
people of other skin color can do as
well so yeah I definitely think it's
it's moving in a way that's more
representative of our world and and I
just hope that you know you know I feel
like with black panther and crazy rich
Asians right I hope that you know it
just it's not just an Asian thing I mean
it's just like a whole I want I want
movies to look like what the real world
looks like yeah yeah I keep waiting for
that Latino superhero but it isn't
and yet right here I'll be his dad I'm
doing but no but I want to see at some
point K um with the so the the the
experience on in humans what can you
submit what can we say about them and
walk the line it didn't salary you on
coming back to the Marvel Universe right
because you had a good time playing
right now may not have worked out
overall but what's what do you take from
that experience I guess is what I would
ask you so Marvel ABC they were great I
mean obviously they had a great track
record with shows so when I got the job
I was like oh yeah obviously things
don't always work out the way you
planned them to do but because of that
show you know maybe that door closed but
because of that opportunity other doors
opened and Pat zig and zag and you know
who knows if that show didn't get
cancelled maybe I'm not available to do
this exactly so that's a great way to
look I'm very grateful for Scott buck
and a B Steve Marvel so yeah and it puts
you on the radar if nothing else right
for possibly shang-chi down the road or
Submariner depending on who if they get
the rights for him right or not um I
think you're good as a martial artist
I've watched your stuff on Instagram but
it looks like your wife might be better
and you said this before I was about to
no I've seen your wife your wife has
incredible reach and I mean just great
kicks if you and your wife were to go at
it and now who would take this band I'm
running for the hills
really her legs are longer she she know
she's in all honesty she's awesome she
without her I wouldn't have the capacity
mentally or physically to pursue so many
endeavors so you know yeah she's a
badass
yeah she was a second degree black pup
before I even started so when I walked
into my first class that's how we met
right she was a second degree black belt
already she flipped you and you knew it
was love totally know this her mom was
one of your teachers yeah so that's
pretty badass so you keep it on the
family and you all co-owned the martial
artists studio that you have right yeah
we coned one in st. Paul Minnesota okay
but then we left to LA right and we came
back and when it was we opened a new
yeah when I came back to Madison
Wisconsin that's when I opened my own
that was the first school that I opened
on my own right off well shout out to
what I had you know I like she scares me
all right let's move on to the last
question that when I ask for a paper
what wisdom from Bruce Lee would you
like to impart to the fans that are
watching or listening to this video and
are fighting to pursue their dreams just
like you did for a number of years is
there a piece of wisdom that you hold on
to that helps you that maybe might help
them out there yeah absolutely you know
there's an interview that I you know had
on repeat it was the Pierre Berton show
you know the black oh yes so many of
those great quotes come from and of
course I could you know go with the
obvious answer a lot to my friend you
know but I really do it as a Bruce Lee
boy through my best you know I kind of
shed that voice so might my voice might
not be as good but he said something
about you know the word stall and it
really turns me off and he would rather
have people consider him a super actor
right than a celebrity or a star and you
know when you're young and I when I got
in this business of course you get your
first gig people are treating you a
certain way and that's nice but now that
I've kind of matured and have been
around a little bit it really while it's
nice to talk with you and be on these
awesome sets and interviews and stuff
what I really want to do is just improve
as a performer whoever improve as an
artist so that's great when when the
trailer comes out and I'm getting all
this love it feels great but ultimately
I feel proud because all of the work
that I put in is being recognized mostly
like I get to feel like oh god I did it
like after so many doors have shut so
many trials tribulations I just want to
become better at my craft yeah I think
that's one of the great things and
reading interviews with you in the past
that's one of the things that drives you
this idea to be one of the best actors
in the room and one of the best martial
artists in the room one of the best
stunt actors as well so that's great to
have that drive and I personally am very
happy to have gotten the time with you
Mike and this film once upon a time in
Hollywood you all have mastered
Tarantino fans it's coming out in July
26 but this is the guy you got to look
out for this one he's about to blow up I
got a feeling so thanks so much thanks
for taking the time nice to meet you
Mike all right we'll see you next time
remember to like and share this video
on your social media and subscribe to
Collider for more interviews and more
videos just like this